all right you're beautiful beautiful
[ __ ] we're playing a game here called
a detention now obviously I've never
been in detention so this really scares
me
let's do this I think it's like time
whinnies or something mmm okay what
they're in this hello sorry class the
following materials in part pay
attention this will be the final exam
during this time period many military
leaders what oh [ __ ] honestly the
president started in northern expedition
securing got that dock look it's
instructor by ie he's gonna see them
sleeping and beat the [ __ ] out of me now
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's all [ __ ] done it
misty and may have a word with you oh
she's all [ __ ] up now okay class let's
take a short break
oh it's gonna be [ __ ] up here it's
gonna be [ __ ] up I've seen way too
many horror films to not now see we
[ __ ] up Miss yen I guess this is the
first chapter have you seen this list
before oh my god oh my god [ __ ] no one
[ __ ] bothered oh I can help it's
what's [ __ ] 6 p.m. oh [ __ ] did I fall
asleep yeah no [ __ ] this is strange
where is everybody
how come nobody's hair that's a good ask
question ellipsis ellipsis ellipsis a
typhoon alert on the board should be two
typhoons this time of year he'll know
what's going on here oh may tell laid
out
yeah just his webcam actually it's kind
of going crazy okay there we go back to
basics baby but actually I just move
this all the way over here oh my god
we're golden
I can look out the window the sound of
howling wind okay that's fine
thankfully much we're getting close at
that side whoa this is so dope it's
getting dark ash go home what is that
what is that there's a note on the table
added during a word admission go whoever
was passing this note in class worried
about Missy end he called sick little
it's weird
no kidding man I hate those other
subjects ended [ __ ]
let's go anthem decent melody school
motto and rolls the first thing in
orientation was a memory school modern
all that honestly brave little stuff
yeah okay I'll put it my netbook
okay this is my seat let's say can I see
what this says I think it's this typhoon
alone I'm guessing right thank you don't
work I thought the weather was quite
nice during class okay before we go
outside let me just check to see what
the [ __ ] else is out here okay and then
we couldn't make it going Batman it's
making Cape Cod case we got that door
what what is this it's a bulletin board
Hall is your thing I hate that you're
marking the calendar of daily weekly
quizzes but term exams final exams
rating this give me a headache
holy [ __ ] get that [ __ ] out of here
that's [ __ ] dirty out here oh no I
can't I got it it's the room I just
[ __ ] got out of so what is that it's
our class schedule did I sleep through
all the afternoon classes you [ __ ]
embarrassing before it go in there the
[ __ ] all this is doors locked
what's in there it's awful quiet have
they all gone in don't know quiet the
classroom I see what this is a piece of
paper lies in the windowsill sketch of
the old banyan tree I [ __ ] loved
abondon tree
she's to be a figure underneath some
dude okay [ __ ] out here
there was locked upstairs and downstairs
okay we're do stairs let's get this
let's get this floor covered okay and
actually let's it's going here front
gate isn't this way oh I'm trying to go
to the front gate don't you see what's
in the rest of this floor this is the
room I was coming from yes
you know [ __ ] pale what's in here
girls restroom shouldn't be gone in
there I don't use the restroom we're not
going upstairs the front gates probably
downstairs so let's do this alright what
is all this and it's a public
announcement I found or what do the
ongoing war with mainland China
instructor buys that's used to router
anyone who maybe pro-communist hmm big
reward so I bet someone [ __ ] put
Missy Anna's at that see what's over
here
they said mr. Kyra sometimes sleeping
here it's locked I don't think anyone's
in there look in there mr. Kyle Colonel
CAI as we call me on his back as
military veteran okay let's go let's go
let's go let's go
oh [ __ ] get in here what a [ __ ]
creepy in here
turn on this light jump-scare time
that yeah sure
I hand Craig let me just steal [ __ ] I
guess holy [ __ ] Diamond Sutra I would
someone put this on the wall butyou're
teachings 130 raincoat are fine what is
this a kerosene heater it's [ __ ]
disgusting so I gotta say let's get the
[ __ ] out of here I think it's the
control panel for the roll-up door open
it yes
can't see [ __ ] mechanical winter
instructors on the cover I think I need
a hand crank there you go babies
let's get the [ __ ] out of here ma'am let
me just check anything else over here
real quick Oh papa growing deaf photos
there's something in the dirt take it
out of course an old photograph what is
that
I can't tell dozen pictures of quote the
Ruth beneath the earth claim no rewards
for making branches beautiful hell yeah
brother yeah yeah I don't know how they
planted so those valuable stuff fits his
office also locked okay it's go outside
then because he's trying to get to the
front gate okay so let's say what the
[ __ ] might be going on here get the [ __ ]
out of here it's beautiful yeah well the
our design is beautiful here I [ __ ]
love this
how about Ray's get in here yeah I guess
it's one person can get the shortest
route back home was through the
auditorium enter yes [ __ ] do this
house this match
hello that Miss young that foggy down
out right here hmm okay yeah the job
I've been waiting for you
it's me messy on detention
if I could sleep on it now and go can I
help you miss him that's gosh a sleeping
hello she's not responding should I get
the stage hell yeah brother maybe have
your rifle ready though I've seen this
movie way too many times can I help you
ask that
hello [ __ ] here's the first jump scare
wake up you shouldn't be here she's
[ __ ] deceased
where am I the auditorium we were
sleeping on the stage huh
suppose cancel the typhoon is coming hey
man I just came from my class agree the
first person I've come across weird how
did I we should get going it's getting
dark in here and they're wearing is
starting to pour what my necklace is
gone what have you say my necklace and
I'll think so I must have lost it
somewhere I'm not leaving without it and
I can't sit yours that [ __ ] so I sit
here [ __ ] you God okay let's just check
the [ __ ] she go
some odds and ends nothing special here
I don't mind a [ __ ] necklace right
there something's in there but I can't
reach it
hello looks like the powers off the dam
sound coming from the end of the shaft
okay so that's the necklace at least if
I post in class signs I keep them
Briella to get it Kenny brother bucket
take it broken okay mm that's not we're
gonna do this [ __ ] get it get it get
it
we got at the white jade deer pen debes
he as taking candy from a baby who
doesn't like candy okay where's that
[ __ ] man
ma'am would it be too much trouble
well we'll certainly find a faster look
together thank you that it's looking for
a deer shape okay we got it baby yeah is
this the necklace yeah I found it that's
all so let's go where did you find it
when the sword Marissa staged it seems
like someone threw it in the bed there
huh I would have been in such a place
well forget it you found it anyways
let's get going before the rain gets
having sure get the [ __ ] out of here
baby
[ __ ] slobs my office Matt let's go
cuz they waited to come through the
auditorium nice trait the AIDS pen
d'etre okay if you dangers to stay here
any longer let's go yeah yeah no [ __ ]
lady you're the one I found [ __ ]
sleeping and here to get your gear
necklace I just say welcome sit here for
a while now people say it fell from the
mountain I can't beat the [ __ ] out of
here what's in here secured officer let
me get I guess even the guard look for
home here's the campers exit security uh
Kenny get the [ __ ] out of here
oh now what the bridge collapsed no
freakin way
we're done right ancestor my god God why
does the river red it looks like it
looks like men shale fluid oh my god
don't say that
sorry I wasn't thinking what happened
okay let's calm down and think about it
there's got to be a reason elimination
hmm
why is it red even money water shouldn't
be this color ah I think I know that
cause of this there if you factory
located upstream it's probably the
dumping chemical waste did the cover the
typhoon are you sure hell yeah baby all
right you're right the worst part is we
don't have to go any we don't have any
way to go downtown with the bridge gone
tons of people cross this bridge every
day the bridge should have met better
with Dan just head back to school we'll
just any good okay you back this cob
epic you like a reliable person okay
let's go up a bit
let's go she's gonna be yeah I hope that
up shows me uh a chance you had me I'm
over 18 you know right eight let's sign
all wet and tired what a day just rest
up for it up didn't she just [ __ ]
sleep the whole time
oh wait I haven't officially thank you
for finding my necklace
I'm fan Gration as a senior from misty
in this class you can call me right
how about yeah but grad you wouldn't
know you're my senior miss Fang I'm
Wayde King
you know I have to be formal three it's
a bit awkward just really is fun
normally we don't go to the senior
building but I heard that it's a very
competitive environment where everyone
works their butt off studying it's not
that awful some will still do what we
want I do envy you for graduating soon
so you won't have to say go Fung on a
daily basis anymore Chuck thereby even
dare call him by his whole name
how mary says he was over a lot less
killer during the war i want to dare to
do that in front of him a that we're all
pretty terrified of him we avoid him in
a puzzle where we can't badges ah yeah
I addict my wife led with the copies
well the perfect imitation give me
goosebumps anyways just hang on tight
buddy
lb here trying to graduate next year I
just struggle hey I know what we can do
you guys that phone in there principle I
was rigging a thought can to anyone and
I'll grab that heater in the storage
room and a couple blankets from Health
Center that should be enough for to get
through the night oh yeah baby
mmm the man's got under control holy
[ __ ]
don't take me to unspool pampers girls
probably more capable than most ei boys
yeah it's okay saying sorry he's gonna
go make the phone call there we gonna
get what we need worth I was at upstairs
her [ __ ] downstairs I can't remember
where let's go baby
then I can't get that way that [ __ ] out
it on here yeah that's fine just does
some hypnosis [ __ ] again the [ __ ] is
happening here huh his footsteps echoed
softly broking a trace of suspense at me
reality faded away as time sits still I
swallowed hard as the emptiness can find
me it's a college
[ __ ] is this physically at the end of a
[ __ ] demo and I'm anyway
what happened it looks like he's not
breathing at all is he dead
but how he was fine just a moment ago oh
my god I just met you
Tommy this is only a bad dream okay
right take a deep breath there's a
notebook on the stage it's waste journal
so I [ __ ] perished saw him looking
through an earlier perhaps her clothes
to see what happened footing telling
turn the wheel with laws of the universe
to reveal the path ahead okay so he's
had anything new
Wow
I put it on him okay let's get the [ __ ]
out of here
this is [ __ ] disgusting no what the
hell that's about can I go up on the
stage here now I don't like that [ __ ]
the candles match light the way
okay can you go up the stairs now no can
I go in here I said [ __ ] shaking you
said my red flag bearer what does that
say yeah what is this this is where the
necklace was oh it's [ __ ] more [ __ ]
there no book club okay no conversation
just her the teacher started a club for
students and reading some prohibited
books really the whole place was just
for studying and I got that low rat a
dead mouse no water it smells so bad in
here can I use this no get away from me
somehow I got that now that we chrizzy
have you [ __ ] nuts
and if frankly I'd be disgusting okay
keep going you go outside Kenny Danny on
here everything's all [ __ ] up now oh
great
Scarlett Johansson mom honey down here
why is our grave here tombs roped off
this is the Security office let me just
about shrine worship which we died yet
Americans any other than the earth God
what's that thing next to the auditorium
key all right let's do this [ __ ] no
under the key facing the lingered picked
up a shrine look don't be scared when
you see linger just hold your breath and
quietly walk away okay so if I see what
okay where is he okay
kind of walk past them but as I touch
them
ah [ __ ] oh I can all hold my breakfast
so long that's why that's interesting
that is interesting okay let's keep got
auditorium key sings scary
how can you wake up in this nightmare
it's locked [ __ ] but not for a long
[ __ ] phone ringing so I poured it up
move stuff and bring it back sounds like
it's come from the left leave my [ __ ]
speakers you're bad
come over here I'm happy it out though
can we call it a time like this
books and all that [ __ ]
hello sir I said I was gonna try and get
a hold of townspeople maybe they're
calling back hell is this
hello am I stood in front right what hot
someone here was found dead place sent
out hello in anyone having thanked I am
waiting it's heart yeah and that
counselor's office how is this not get a
ride I know where all is going on how
was that how did he that was brain the
counsel's office on the third floor
Pataki got a lie shot I just I write out
right here all different pranks a
progress well yeah but watch that's the
folders empty
third floor thing you said
and not the [ __ ] on here oh great
bloodstains
soon as I got dangerous shown to ban but
what do I know why is that say only a
single destined change sitting in focus
insult some great marks on the table
sheeni words and symbols with the to
thing to read right now
okay
and they on the board
let me see okay I got it
remember these stale bars been here I
just gotta find away the other side
all right go down and across it's fine
good thing I got a good candle and I
like the best from dad I what is this
it's all boarded up that's in there
can't see inside at all how's that [ __ ]
the [ __ ] is this bar Dwyer died young
written on paper this is waste classroom
no [ __ ] that on here
there's no citation alert you're on your
own now I wrote this I is that yeah this
is vice chair so I'm writing out that
strengthen thy wings as sons of limit ah
stricter by gambling is prohibited and
what [ __ ] house that was caught will
be expelled [ __ ] assess oh this was like
the [ __ ] because baths weren't gonna
go in feet we're clear my head that's s
pliers in the sink okay so my head hurts
I look like hell how did way die like
that and I am banned her as well right
there please tell me this is all about a
nightmare
hello ma'am freak out and I just too
afraid to remember holy [ __ ] that was
loud yeah well jump-scare job scare
[ __ ] [ __ ]
what's in here something's jammed in a
pipe a single die that [ __ ] illegal
though check out here
here we go like [ __ ]
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here [ __ ]
dead okay
it's [ __ ] bad I guess I'm good though
okay pliers let me cut this let's do
this [ __ ]
there's a [ __ ] note on the ground now
on the floor food offerings put down
offering to Revere that lingered then
hold your breath and do not linger okay
I don't have any [ __ ] fit safe
station
so I could put this down food offering
how's my eyesight there's a shadow in
the corner pull the board up yes
they got it in a [ __ ] medical supply
storage came [ __ ] yeah you guys gonna
[ __ ] yourself several documents patient
records
how come students would be injured or so
severe like this right are broken the
[ __ ] doors lock from the other side well
this is the key you say them again
okay that I do this
about
we did it oh [ __ ] door's unlocked
[ __ ] that's Davis [ __ ] messy in
here birches showers and I wash up into
the water but another dying now we could
[ __ ] gamble it's [ __ ] disgusting
let's head here though sharp smell come
for the middle block paint Center okay
I'm locking the door I can get in now Oh
so I can go around that whole person the
[ __ ] was I doing right what the [ __ ] is
my objective clip now turn the wheel
with laws of universe to reload about
that
now if I'm disgusting
um okay so maybe I can go down to the
first floor and go all the way to the
right than that up I know that that [ __ ]
is that
[Music]
sitting around here yep okay let me go
here and go all the way across here
[ __ ] it's okay I can't Spokane they get
the whole way across
No
can I get that through thing back oh my
god I just [ __ ] run
don't have anything just [ __ ] around
for it
the [ __ ]
how'd I get by last time
okay so I lost that food
I gotta get the [ __ ] I think I'm still
trying to get to the other room so what
has always [ __ ] gamble right here
paint thinner
right a gamble here what is that
and do anything
what was that
who was that out
I bet you're by yourself yeah exactly
sure what to do here
turn the wheel missus get back to the
original spot
I really go up to the third floor again
you know could be something there mr.
McKinney huh yeah would think I'd learn
that you can't drink double IPAs like
they're Millers hey Thea what was this
again just a medical room yeah
this doesn't do anything paint dinner
don't do anything okay
he's get the [ __ ] out of here that can I
ask the deer for like [ __ ] help or
something find a way through the other
side [ __ ] sucks okay makes it go all
the way I think a where I could go I
guess it'd go all the way back down to
the auditorium I need to get
okay no no I don't want to go there cuz
it's [ __ ] locked okay let's see here
can I go
don't go this way yet
can you save a pretty nice guy that's
terrible yeah [ __ ] was that
okay so we have we have woody here we
have bars upstairs so I can't do [ __ ] on
3rd and 2nd floor and I just can't do
[ __ ] so let me go back to the first
floor sit the [ __ ] going on here this
was that one room they might get the
food again to distract them there's a
one time thing that's more fit ok so
then I can go back to the first floor
and get past that one [ __ ]
she's [ __ ] disgusting first four
plays first floor
okay now let's get past this [ __ ]
all right or American babies wait i
Melvin
not going that way this auditorium well
what the [ __ ] is going on here
cows room what's on the door Talisman's
painted on it since strange block but I
got paint thinner so it's fine
really move tell [ __ ] now he's gonna be
[ __ ] freak let's see what the [ __ ]
disaster is here country map the point
of knowing place is so distant it's a
nice dad in the tape let's put the rest
it looks sharp okay I got my night babe
a free calendar every household has one
and it's that post your favorite
celebrity hello what's in here
I'm sure the alcohol spoke I'm
suffocating
ship Titanic bull can't lift it up some
of us stuck the table
scratching marks guess the room were
young people gamble it was my room after
all okay well before I [ __ ] gamble
let me see what this is real quick a
water bucket something's in here another
die hell yeah brother might throw up
okay I guess we're gamblin toss it and
baby
oh that [ __ ] tape what's this
okay that was holding dice we're sorry
dice so it's six to three okay that
sound have all came loose that I got a I
get the ball okay you guys ready for
jump scare town because this jumps got
time now
oh the [ __ ] letter here now cutting
throughout prosecutors revealed when a
second person made the blood the
anisette okay
disturbing is fun let's go right and
then I say for myself right here was
last times up David Bolton oh yeah this
is um [ __ ] what was it again
four to three
I'm [ __ ] nervous impose that way
honey
[ __ ]
and you know if I can't change it
can opens I know how to read these words
symbols hit the [ __ ] it's the [ __ ]
four three two effect well there's a
library upstairs how do I get past this
[ __ ] now
any foodie gonna be a past themself they
can wake up from this nightmare spit
still here yeah
oh yeah you gotta get the blood of the
innocent okay
let's ring it to that ball a bowl of
blood what the [ __ ] he's awake he's a
[ __ ] wake I saw you I saw you [ __ ]
okay
I can saw that [ __ ] anything you in
here miss their mouse mr. Morelle
I get the [ __ ] out of here okay so my
guest says we get it either go through
the book place upstairs or yeah to like
find out what the symbols mean or we
have to go to that like there was a
scratch on the table you can tell it how
it was so let's see what to find out
really quickly oh we can't go that way
so
just turn that wheel [ __ ] that means
let me go back outside just in case
there's like it's a shrine tell me you
have to put this blood there something
[ __ ] maybe I like too [ __ ] far you
know how I work for so [ __ ] long made
the earth God protect me doing anything
[ __ ]
we gotta get going
Jesus [ __ ]
okay alright so you got the ball of
blood the person still dripping
everywhere
there's not a lot of place I could go I
could really just go there right again
that's about it because they can't get
past that person
anything unique in here
[ __ ] assist me I gotta put this blood in
here something
it is bottle
ya know there's not really much place
sounds like I go
at 10:00
strewth combination lock can't open
listened to how to read these symbols so
I got to get past that person I don't
[ __ ] know how but I got to do it
I have been turning around [ __ ] [ __ ] am
I supposed to do that we're gonna stop
this episode here maybe we will see
what's next
um I hope y'all a happy I hope y'all are
happy what is this
can I try this on there and this [ __ ] I
think I gotta do more [ __ ] with this guy
sir your eyes are [ __ ] open I know
they were take a headlock do anything
any more blood sir let me check out its
note one more time they turned into what
it's supposed to have an something
prophecies revealed no it's not [ __ ]
real
turn the would laws the universe so the
only will I [ __ ] now is so we'll try
them one more time in here see what may
be going on this is the only whale I
[ __ ] know if you see it Haidee else
in here filled with trash
so my next run here can ask her what
details down and why was I sleeping on
stage I'm clueless yeah you're [ __ ]
clueless
alright well anyway we ran end is here
and we'll see y'all the next episode
thank ya